this show is sponsored by nature box
nature box ships great tasting healthy
snacks right to your door forget the
vending machine and start snacking
smarter
i'm doing good right now not you i'm
still laughing at that [ __ ] potion
he told me
[ __ ] celery what you say spinach no
spinach almond butter seven dates day
ice cream okay you gotta stop what is
pretty hey you gotta stop you're making
me depressed
you you wanna beat up pluto or what i
don't give a [ __ ] about pluto though how
are you eating [ __ ] noodles
are you eating [ __ ] spinach like that
in a blender with a banana that's not
that's delicious dude i'm telling you
you're gonna try it oh you're just
getting the flashback you can't even
taste the spinach that's the best part
after with the other [ __ ] that's in
there you gotta taste nothing you don't
want to taste it you just sit there why
am i drinking this for breakfast you
know what it is you had me you had me
with the seven ice cubes what else
almond meal common milk almond butter
seven dates
then your banana the [ __ ] dates why
are the dates in there dates don't do
nothing sweeten it up right oh have
cinnamon it tastes like horchata yeah
that's how they sell it to you
in the bathroom ten minutes later
[ __ ]
with spinach strings coming out of your
[ __ ] you're gonna read the [ __ ]
sponsors you're gonna sit there
i'm not even the one who's in trouble
forget the vending machine and start
snacking smarter with healthy and
delicious treats like dark cocoa almonds
go to naturebox.com joey right now to
unbox the world of taste and possibility
go to nature
go to naturebox.com joey for your first
box of beyond tasty hand-picked snacks
send direct to your doorstep
lee be like i ain't leaving that vending
machine though
you read me on these i'm not yet i'm
doing it right now you're still on
[ __ ] nature box yeah you [ __ ] come
on guys
we're doing it we need two [ __ ]
minutes to get this yeah you interrupted
let's do it in 21 minutes go to
meundies.com joey and get 20 off of your
first order of all the great men's and
women's underwear t-shirts socks
sweatpants sweatshirts go to
myundates.com joey and they're going to
give you 20 off of your first order with
free shipping in the united states and
canada
and go to onit.com and use codeword
church to get 10 off all the great
optimization products like alpha brain
strong bone new mood stream tech immune
stream tech support code world church to
get 10 off
crank that lovely yeah you're [ __ ]
around tonight whistles we ain't going
out when spanish people start whistling
it's all over kick that lead
kick it leave the music not you you [ __ ]
kick it oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
the church [ __ ]
september 16th
2015.
kicking it mexican it's abandoned
independence day right yeah
oh [ __ ]
i never go back to georgia
[ __ ] tremendous these puerto ricans
tremendous go back
drop flip up keep [ __ ] playing that
little rhythm are you kidding me or what
half these [ __ ] mutts are probably
going to sleep kick that [ __ ]
damn 10 10.
are you [ __ ] kidding me can you
imagine having these puerto ricans in
next audio and they do rehearsal on
tuesday nights they're frying bananas
you just sitting in your room like a
[ __ ] bumpy talking to your mother her
name is louise she's boring you to
pieces and also these [ __ ] spicks are
next door listening to this [ __ ] what
are you gonna do you stab your mother
and put it under the [ __ ] couch like
jeffrey dahmer so [ __ ] you you bored me
to pieces you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm going
next door with the space i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah something good is coming out
of that [ __ ] doorknob i'll be able to
plate because when this [ __ ] was planned
this is 1960 late 60s early 70s
people still in manhattan the irish
the italian the jewish they weren't
[ __ ] cool with these people and also
they showed up with bongo drums and [ __ ]
they know how to [ __ ] act what's
going on felipe what's up
smiley tonight
silent bob is here the original rodrigo
torres hell yeah family member attorney
in the future
just came back from mexico
eating scorpions did you see cartels at
all they're uh where the place where i'm
at was that
in the middle right next to jalisco and
uh chapo's people have been moving in
there for like the last year taking out
the cetas they were there before they're
actually bothering people extorting
people and then moving their [ __ ]
but uh nah they don't [ __ ] with you you
don't [ __ ] with them that's just all
like if you you know i mean
watching money if you ain't in bed with
them you don't have nothing to worry
about what did you go back what did you
go for not bad just seven days i went to
go so my cousin got married
like my cuz paula's mom won't go back
unless it's to like she'll never go back
to georgia
well she'll go back to like see visit
her son briefly but like she won't go
anywhere else she's scared
of that all that [ __ ] going on yeah
like it's more hype than anything but if
you don't go back there you are [ __ ]
susceptible to that man head changes
then her like paula's aunt comes and she
still lives in mexico and she said like
down there like moms hope that their
daughters marry drug dealers like it's
like
what makes the most money and even
though it's dangerous like that's what
she said i don't know if that's true
[ __ ] being poor dog
it's either if you're in politics there
or that [ __ ] or if you like mad business
people and the biggest industrial places
in mexico is
mexico city monterrey and [ __ ] uh
guadalajara you know it's real
interesting if you the border towns you
bump into [ __ ] people now and you get
into a conversation
within the first eight minutes narcos
comes up
it's all [ __ ] everybody's talking
popping right now it's weird that
as i have you know i'm going to watch it
again you know i'm going to watch it all
are you really
a netflix thing yeah you got to watch it
i'm watching i'm watching it right now
you're watching it and it's pretty
interesting episode um what it did
what it did you know everybody talks
about bruce lee
i had you know people talk about elvis i
heard uh
i heard a [ __ ] elvis song
we could go on the radio dog i had to
pull over
i'm serious by bank of america had to
pull over to the right and you might
pick myself up in the car it hit you
hard uh what the [ __ ] was just a regular
stupid elvis song
you know people that lived to see
in the beginning yeah can you imagine
being around when elvis came on you got
to see that
you know i don't understand that i don't
understand how we we we were a little
younger we didn't see the beatles at
shea stadium there was how many people
there that welcomed the beatles and
people were fainting i've been around a
thousand people i never saw nobody
fainting but in the 60s people would
faint and yell and you know we weren't
around to see that so we don't know that
feeling bro
i was there to see bruce lee i was very
fortunate to be in a room with ten
little boys we're just out of a shower
in a catholic school and we gotta sit
around with another and watch tv at
night and all of a sudden the commercial
for a chinese connection came on and
there was silence
silence he sucked the energy out of the
room like he was doing the green horn
and you know there was a chinese guy in
the green hornet and his name was kato
and he threw kicks now it was completely
different so i got to live it and then
he died and i got to see how it changed
the country in your lifetime you guys
have
that
fortune to see things how it happened
we're seeing this weed revolution you
grew up in los angeles 15 years 20 years
ago they bust you down and [ __ ]
wherever you're from be called the rain
whether the [ __ ] garden is
right so now you've seen it you've seen
the wheat stores to me it was very
foreign i remember
and i tell people this all the time bro
i was there with felipe we were 15. and
we would take little hits a mess going
and giggle and smoke pot and hook up
with the gargoulo brothers on 76th
street and then we'd crush the mescaline
up and smoke it and at the end of the
night you and i came home and you'd say
coco what'd you spend six dollars
we bought us we split a 12 pack of nips
there were four something two dollars a
piece and it was three for the hit of
masculine
everybody in this country was set on
masculine and a little reef and a little
[ __ ] beard and all of a sudden
some kid called you into a room and said
come here for a second
you ever do this bro
what is it it's cocaine
what are you talking about do this smell
it it's a powder bro it's amazing you
could [ __ ] for hours
if you play basketball you could slam
dunk
in fact when you jump off the basket the
whole thing how much a hundred dollars
i got a hundred [ __ ] dollars
and all of a sudden i saw the evolution
also i seen it hit i seen black people
running around harlem with no shoes on
looking for crap you know then you saw
the crack epidemic yeah you were holding
up the seat and lived through
so
now you're seeing it from the back end
oh that's where it comes from
that's where it comes from it started in
[ __ ] chile and the cockroach
didn't die and he made it to colombia
and he sold the package to [ __ ]
escobar and escobar figured out how to
[ __ ] move it across the border not
one kilo
60 kilos and then 120 kilos and then you
know next thing you know what were they
moving 2 000 and you can't when you see
these statistics you can't really
believe this like if you look at this
okay so they were getting they were
smuggling a ton is 2 000 pounds right so
they were saying they were smuggling
what a month into the united states
two metric tons two measures i used to
get so coked up and i'm making a
confession to everybody here when i
during my addiction the 30-year
addiction i went through different
phases i went through the mathematical
joey diaz
there's a mathematical joey diaz that
would get coked up and start figuring
out if he had a kilo and he cut it with
20 ounces how much he would make and how
much if he distributed this i swear to
god then i became the musical joey diaz
where i started taking out encyclopedias
and looking at history of music bands
and what if earthworm and fire got
together with casey and the sunshine
band you know what i'm saying like who
would be the bass player what are you
talking about you have no [ __ ] idea
what i'm talking about okay that's the
waste of time and then i got into the
into the what was the other joey diaz
there was like six different joey deers
oh you have no idea whenever i did
cocaine it was another mind [ __ ] i
wanted to be alone because i wanted to
get a piece of paper and pen and i'd
become philosophical joey diaz and try
to write like ben franklin quotes
[ __ ] terrible but you go through all
these dumb
things with coke you know like you get
the paranoia when i first did coke
nobody got paranoid
nobody people did coke and
giggles what's up dog i love you they
tell you long stories and [ __ ] for hours
you gotta sit there make believe and
[ __ ]
you know and then all of a sudden people
like hold on one second you hear that
and also when people come over and [ __ ]
up your whole party because they'd hear
voices yeah let me look out the window
and i'm saying you're like let me look
out there you know everybody's looking
at the [ __ ] windows gotta go
my [ __ ] the neighbors seeing [ __ ]
doors going back and forth people coming
in and out people coming at us but it's
really interesting to see this narco
show
because it shows you their perspective
of they were how they were attacking us
with cocaine well they they said at the
end they were making 65 million a day
like more than gm like not more than not
65 million more but say more than gm 65
million dollars a day taxes a day 60
million a day guys
and who's the number one [ __ ]
exporter of that
we are
we are consuming he doesn't sell that to
a pharmacy no he didn't sell that to
rouse
at wholesale or he didn't go to cvs
he sold that to [ __ ] people who are
going to move that if you figure that
out
into what we were snorting in the
beginning you you'd be how much how
crazy we went
so here's the only question i had about
the show
they fly it over to miami right yeah
is it's the yearning for wanting more
guys
you know uh john singleton is shooting
this pilot about in fx about drugs in
the 80s everybody's going to knock this
out of the park now everybody's going to
hit this topic how this whole epidemic
started
everybody's going to hit this topic
and the part i read was about a boxer
who wasn't doing [ __ ] with his life
and he looked up one day and he saw a
spanish guy come in with gold and rings
and
you know taking hundreds from people and
tapping his nose and he said [ __ ]
getting punched in the head
you know for 25 to fight i'm gonna go
sell [ __ ] blow and that's what
happens
i've met a thousand drug dealers in my
life i was involved with drugs
for 30 years i met guys that were
confused men
that were doing drugs to get chicks and
to get that dick sucked and to play the
mafia role or the gangster roll out
and i met guys who were businessmen who
were brilliant
brilliant i had a white dude in boulder
that dude was brilliant bro
he was selling a ton of [ __ ] bluff
but he was also building a business
empire in the daytime that's how he was
fueling the money
for the stereo we had the body shop with
the [ __ ] gps he had the rims the
electric rims so the snow would melt off
your tires this guy was badass but if
you call this guy at three in the
morning he was right there bush eyed
wide eyed selling coke and i had mine i
still own 1500
out of respect no i've had drug dealers
from every
shape form and size
and i've learned something from each of
them i've noticed the ones like the
suckers
you know for
15 years i just prayed on drug dealers
and all i had to see was an opening
and once i saw that opening
they'll continue this but this is the
point i was going to bring up go ahead
what's the point how do you as a drug
dealer how do you defend against what
you made your living off of being a
[ __ ] professional
staying on top of your game like
anything else because i'm not the only
barracuda on you
what do you think i'm the only barracuda
on a drug deal there's 18 guys watching
you waiting to make a mistake they used
to um sell drugs i'm right across the
street from my mom's house on fifth
street and they were starting to crack
there all the time
and i would um
walk down the street to fourth street
to cut the cars off before they went to
fifth street
so i was stopping everybody like
everybody was driving on fifth street to
buy crack but me and my friends you know
why would we just stand on fourth street
and cut these cars off before they go to
fifth street so man we started short
stopping everybody that's a genius move
yeah and then after that once everybody
started going on fourth street we said
you know what man we're too fat to be
chasing after these cars what do we
start selling drugs at three in the
morning so what we did was we had
regular five piece of crack and then at
three in the morning we split them in
half so we doubled our money
so i will sell crack bro like
like you you you think about how
desperate these crackheads will come at
three in the morning can i get a 20
and i would give them like a five dollar
piece of crack for 20.
because they'll take it
and um
you know those were the prices and i was
a little crazy little hustler
but sometimes you know my brother like
my brothers is bad because my brother
angel
that for used to [ __ ] up the game man
he was selling um almonds bro
so this food will come back and shoot
everybody so i have to go back to fifth
street
i had a guy that was big on that [ __ ] i
a long time what's the other [ __ ] that
they have before or a job
there's a different embassador
ambassador
the best you could freeze it yeah you
can freeze i don't know how he's doing
it don't ask how to i don't know the
chemical balance i'm not a chemistry
this is
30 [ __ ] years ago i knew this guy
briefly and i know he was doing
something with amber saw because he told
me he would take the coke into the city
i am one of my first cocaine dealers
every time i went to his house this is
why when i saw the movie boogie nights
i knew that dude
the dude with the robe with the chinese
guy with the fireworks i knew that was
my first dog deal
his name was patty d
patty lived around the block from me was
my first drug dealer i ran interference
and between him and one of his relatives
was a cop
they were favorite cousins but since he
become a cop
he couldn't hang out with his cousin
normal and pick up the goods
because he knew they were watching his
cousins
so i would see the cop in the afternoon
after school and he'd give me an
envelope
i'd walk over the patties get what i had
to get take a couple bumps off the top
and at night the cop would come home and
get his little envelope
that's how i knew the guy but
so now
just right after my mom died bro 15. i'm
15.
i'm hanging out at patty dee's house in
the meantime i'm hanging out with diddy
kantara and his brother carlos
and carlos is his unofficial bodyguard
people thought paddy d was a little gay
but they weren't sure you know what i'm
saying
but everything
sorry about that guy's my allergies
every time he went over he had a robot
and you didn't know and he would sing
songs and [ __ ] like he'd play music just
like that dude in [ __ ] motor and and
boogie nights that's what he plays right
same thing bro
if you when you went over there you knew
you had to sit there for 20 minutes and
get it here beating about the chick you
just [ __ ] that you never saw
you never saw none of his women mm-hmm
you just missed his bro you just
mistreated me the hardest chick i [ __ ]
up for two hours i she sucked my dick i
ate her ass you just missed her she
would have sucked your dick if you got
hit ten minutes early that's a control i
have over a woman what do you want
and then
and then you tell him let me get a gram
you know i got 80 bucks how much you owe
me give me 80 bucks and then you'd wait
for a line and he'd give you the
smallest [ __ ] line he'd do a big big
line in between that he played music and
he started doing like the video dance to
the music and [ __ ] you'd sit there bored
to pieces like oh no
when is he going to take his dick out so
i could just kill this [ __ ]
oh my god and then
carlos he accused carlos of breaking
into his house
so the relationship ended but i bumped
into him on facebook and we friended
each other and then when he realized
that i was part of the [ __ ]
conspiracy he unfriended me
unbelievable these [ __ ] people he was
the weirdest dude ever always had a robe
on two in the afternoon ten at night and
just finished [ __ ] the trick you just
missed them you missed it bro
phantom chicks thought you should have
been there bro she was hot bro i was
doing blow up her nipples
it was awesome
bit that [ __ ] and then my high school
teacher
the camel
the camel told me that if i couldn't get
a hold of him ever he goes there's a
buck he goes i wouldn't tell you this
but there's a spot on 135th and
amsterdam
it's a discotheque downstairs
it's colombians and dominicans it's the
first merge
it's the first the colombians became
partners of the dominicans this is
i'm taking you [ __ ] back to new
york 1983.
you'd have to park your car and answer
that
and he'd have 15 guys out there
as a
parking maze there was no there was no
meters no no there was no valets
you parked your car you got and there
was a guy right there okay okay get it
okay and you you give him five dollars
and he said he'd walk you
that was their scam they'd walk into the
discotheque
then you walk downstairs the place would
be packed
in the daytime they would play colombian
music but at night they would play disco
music whatever if you're thinking yeah
that's it right
so you walk in you'd [ __ ] walk and
people be dancing the dj would see you
and in the dj box
there was a guy and he'd go
and right there in front of everybody
dancing
right you'd walk in and the guy would
say i got two powders for you i got this
[ __ ] from colombia i just got off the
boat it's called pigeon anger and i got
this other [ __ ] that's called that
what do you want this is a hundred no
they would only sell grams
and eight balls
this is 110 and this is 250 and this is
280. you give it to them they'd have
four turntables
right in the back three turntables three
they had three two of them were spinning
and one of them would stop they'd take
the aluminum pro it was a 24-hour
business
and then they would open the door and
you see that ledge where the door is and
have a drop
and that's where the package would be
can you take the package out
he'd give you an extra give you two
bumps wrap it up for you and you went
out the back door to the disco and you
pop right up on amsterdam dog and i
remember one day going and the colombian
came out he goes there's a dead dude
there but we got a different way to walk
into the building
they had the yellow tape around them
they had the guy with the blanket he
took blood dripping
and when we pulled up the dude took the
fin from us and took us around the thing
we still they still were selling coke
with the cops in front the investigation
of the murder one time i walked in on
them and they were having a chicken
thing with the chickens fighting and
[ __ ] tremendous
this is
a real dog this was real studio 55 yeah
i forget i forget the name of the place
this was a long [ __ ]
it's weird the drug dealers you i could
write a book about my [ __ ] drug
dealers that's not a bad idea every one
of them the ones i found [ __ ]
interesting is [ __ ]
my drug dealers always been real small
little mexican ladies
how old like old dude like i used to buy
drugs in um
in um elysian valley i used to live in a
legion valley in frogtown where milo
rivera grew up so i used to go to that
river
and they used to be an old lady bro
she used to hang up by the river this
old lady bro like she must have been
like 60 years old she looked like she
was
wearing one of those work dresses like
those little aprons that moms wear over
and she'll just hang out with a with a
bunch of shopping bags full of groceries
they were just fake groceries and still
have a little
weed container like those green little
bottles
full of crack i mean full of the most
flattest crack it look like pinot
burrito okay wait is that good i don't
know man i just smoked anything that's
crack
i don't know the difference this is the
back of the day this is
2003. felipe looking good 2003 bro
that was back
river dancing in the rivers of frog town
so this lady was asking me bro
i should have a beeper number and i
would call her and then she'll meet me
outside but if i would and then she
couldn't cross over the river because
she's paying taxes to the gang across
the river so if she goes to cross the
river she has to pay taxes to this gang
so i would meet her halfway through the
river
so
i would give her 60 dollars and she'll
give me like a bunch of flattish crack
but and then
one time she wasn't there man and i had
to walk all the way inside was i was
this old cuban dude bro there's probably
been a drug dealer and a pimp and a drug
addict in that little area since
they used to be a cuban neighborhood all
of atwater
back in the days and um
he was he had a he was inside the alley
river
inside a tent
he had his own little tent set up inside
the bushes and he just took his hand out
and i gave him 40 dollars and he gave me
40 dollars to crack crazy dog
just a tent in the bushes
a tent bro
and it was like that was so bad
and then um
and then after she would leave she would
have to leave at 10 o'clock i knew her
hours bro like i knew that she got to
the neighborhood at 11 in the morning so
sometimes i would drive with my volvo
and be waiting like a [ __ ] like a mouse
bro waiting like a like a fiend bro
every time the bus
a bus shows up i get excited i start
dancing like samuel jackson she took the
bus drugs
bro she was like i'm telling you bro if
you want to survive a drug theater like
joe diaz said you don't flash your money
you show up man she shows up like an old
lady about to clean somebody's house
and
she how some i got i will give her
something i will bring her doritos and
she'll give her an extra little chip
a chip for a chip
times were bad bro
but
but man and then when she would leave at
10 i would have to go to drew street and
this is before i knew i didn't know that
this was a
crazy gang you know i saw him in gang
land and i'll be over there man
and this old mexican man will meet me at
seven in the morning at this clinic and
he'll put coke
he'll put crack cocaine instead of a big
ass mexican um um virote a french roll
and he'll like he'll drop off his kids
at school
go pick up a mexican bread and puddle
and he'll open up a concha mexican bread
and put crack in there and he'll hand me
over a piece a bag of bread
and he'll be on his way
man i was doing a lot of crap man
i couldn't stop
i ain't mad it was good though sometimes
people do crap one time man i could i
had a showcase [ __ ] i had a coach
man never forget that man you came
through like a like a like a thief in
the night bro you came in bro
blasting bran like the guns of never
ruined bro i was two days without
sleeping and ivan calls you up and he
got philippe the showcase today at eight
o'clock but i ever slept all day he's
gonna go pick you up they go why are you
gonna pick me up then we remember we
picked you up and we took it to the
7-eleven
then you hung out with us and you were
like damn
i can't have no sleep man pat buckle is
going crazy but i did my showcase man
with my eyes full blast bro like like a
truck driver's eyes man i have been
driving for eight hours my eyes were
beaming me up scotty man
i was like garfield man doing his
showcase that's a nice jacket thank you
man i love it it's a levi jacket thank
you very much oh no it's a regular
jacket
just especially spanish drug dealers
like i had a black drug dealer on 125th
and broadway in 1994 when that song was
popping up mr window
mr window he was developed he was old
and black and he had white hair he was
frail he was a sweetheart and he'd get
blasted on those little bottles not that
pint but the half pint yeah and when you
walked in the bell went off there was
like a couple sodas in the refrigerator
it was a health food store but it was
really a weed store and he would come up
and he had all the drugs like nobody in
that business could you go to the window
and say yo let me see what you got let
me pick a bag no
you put your twenty dollars in and they
throw a bag on you take and you walk out
of there for some reason i got so
personalized with him
that i'd say mr wendell what do you got
show me what you got show me some love
and he blow out like [ __ ] six bags
and i'd say i'm taking one of them but i
take one and drop it on the floor
and give him four back but he was so old
he would just take the four in the 20s i
see the mob player
and i just bend over pick up the 20th
tie and walk out of there it was [ __ ]
though i played
so much with heat on those those harlem
streets right before i left in 85 there
was cuban refugees everywhere in harlem
they were everywhere uh silent bob i had
been out of the game
my mom died in 79 so i had been out of
contact with cuban people all of a
sudden everywhere everywhere everywhere
in new york west new york they're
smacking people they're getting arrested
and [ __ ] that's all the [ __ ] you read
about
like i didn't know really running [ __ ]
too okay one my stepfather was part of
four brothers
that's why they called the family of
cuatro riento the four winds
so three of them were in cuba he paid
ten thousand to get one
he sent them back to cuba after four
days because the guy was a communist
because he saw somebody walking down the
street and they said something to each
other so and they lifted their arm in a
weird way he called him comandante one
of those words my stepfather shipped him
back but then two of his nephews came
four nephews came in 1980 and by 1982
there was only one nephew left three of
them had been shot like dogs in the
street they came out to this violent
they tried to play it a different a
different way
i had grown up a guy
with a guy named dothi that my mom was
friends with that they tried to help out
that guy was pulling those scams when i
was a kid you know you're showing up
with coke and he'd shoot you take the
money and the [ __ ] drugs
that stuff but when those cuban games
that to that area
they [ __ ] took over like this
but they lifted that you know they were
like gangs
they were like gang members here in l.a
they just lifted the violence man
and
let me see
there was a bunch of them that would
sell weed
the bus takes you to 178th from jersey
over the george washington bridge so all
you have to do is walk out of the lake
out of the port authority and make a
right and walk down that block and cut
in left and you'd see a bunch of people
standing on the street they were all
cuban refugees
and they were selling weed
so i would go up to them i became
friends they were selling nickel bags oh
yeah and i become friends with one
particular one you know what i'm saying
i would always buy from him and buy from
him and after about two months i knew i
was leaving to colorado i just asked him
is how do you get involved in this
like you want to sell first i go yeah
i'll help yourself like you'd be great
you know english
they're like you make a thousand dollars
a [ __ ] day so i'm like you make that
much money he's like oh yeah it's not
bad selling weed selling weight here's
the deal this is the deal [ __ ]
for every 25 nickel bags you sell you
keep 25 bucks
that's the that was the level then
that's what you do as a refugee you have
no paperwork you're an illegal maybe
they weren't illegal i don't [ __ ]
know they came with that marielle boat
thing yeah but these guys this is
i couldn't judge those guys even at that
age at 21. i was 21 and 22. i'm like so
tell me again
you sell 25 bags
and you make i go what do you make a day
we make about 150 but you got to be out
here from
lunchtime to two in the morning
that's what you do that's what you did
20 30 years ago when you were
a person who didn't speak english and
you didn't have a way to feed your
family and they made a thousand dollars
a day no i'm telling you that you had
this is what the you know they told me
you make a lot of money when you go to a
denny's when you walk into denny's and
you go i want to be a waiter like that's
a great job you got to make a bunch of
money you don't know what a bunch of
money is
but these guys were out there 12 to 12
selling 12 hours of nickel bags cars
pull up what do you got center media how
much five dollars give me 10 bags let me
look at it let me sniff it let me get 10
for 12. these [ __ ] just go no
it's five dollars a piece it would they
give you 25 bags lee at five dollars
that means you have to give me 125
you keep you keep 25 you give me a
hundred once you give me a hundred
dollars i get another 25 bags you sell
those 25 bags i'll give you you give me
a hundred that's what you do when you're
a drug dealer so this is my office i'm
here watching tv
you're on the corner felipe's on
lancaster and blur bank and silent bars
by the car wash over there right
that's it you guys sell nickelback from
eight in the morning to midnight on
those corners
you know i understand but just like this
they're they'll probably make maybe a
hundred bucks a night
right because they have to sell twenty
five bucks that's what i'm saying if
they sell 100 bags they have to sell 400
bags to make 100 [ __ ] bucks or 400
and in those days you had that type of
volume 10 guys could do that 10 guys
could sell that much weed in a day in
like new york city or anywhere new york
city with that type of volume
and that money just to be sitting down
not working picking up sugar canes or
nothing no you're outside hustling
wheeling and dealing when the cops pick
you up listen there's a raid those
neighborhoods always get red
those neighborhoods get ready every six
weeks
you learn how to a not have stuff on you
and b how to know when the raids are
coming and see how to pay to not make
the raids come if that's your occupation
as a drug deal it's like anything else
you got to dive into it the reason why
and i all and i've always believed this
felipe you yourself like reading mafia
books about history anything organized
crime
the reason why i think the mafia
they lost touch with what was going on
the streets they got so greedy on this
end to me
if i was building a mafia
and you came to me and said joey i want
you to be a captain what's the first job
you're going to do is i'm selling street
corners
because i know in my mind
every street corner is 50 000 a month
i know this that's the bottom end of any
criminal organization is to control a
neighborhood
all we need is three neighborhoods
north hollywood
studio city by laurel canyon and ventura
is ours
and owen and whatever is ours those are
three streets that within a year we're
going to be making 50 000 a [ __ ]
month
selling whatever we want heroin coke on
those corners that's how a drug dealer
that's how a criminal organization looks
at a street corner
every street corner if i had three
street corners and i sell blow on those
corners and i put two bad ass
[ __ ] on those corners to sell
50s of cocaine all day long the uncut
rock aluminum foil all day long they're
there from 12 to 2 in the [ __ ]
morning and you know this no drama
no parking the car going upstairs
don't let my wife know why you're here
none of that [ __ ]
when you're an addict that's where you
go yeah if i tell you i'm gonna be there
with the best cocaine in the city uncut
what are you paying oh silent bomb 60. i
got it for 50. right now in aluminum
foil you my gram's got rocking it for 50
[ __ ] i'm just i don't know what it sells
for i know within 90 days
i'm making 50 000 a month and i'm just
the [ __ ] i'm just the guy that's
picking the coke up and putting the
operation together
i know that for a [ __ ] fact each
corner never mind now what happens if i
put a bodega over there
and that bodega i sell numbers and i
take sports bets
so why are you going to sell the street
corners then because i got to control
the street corners that's how criminal
what do you think the mafia just sells
drugs and the rest no now you have to
take the sports betting now that's
another [ __ ] no that's another
[ __ ] corner you have that's how you
control the corner with that grocery
store and the [ __ ] you got yourself
phone cars too you got a cell phone what
do you sell whatever nobody no no you
keep that place clean you just do sports
gambling there
if they want to come in for a sports
game and let them come in for sports
gambling you have an office somewhere
else that thing is that thing is
well you can't do offshore betting well
you're trying to get the money off the
street felipe
you start with the lowest numbers if
they know i could come to let's say i'm
a [ __ ] spanish immigrant
and i know i got to pay sneakers for my
kid
but life is a [ __ ] and those
immigrants know it's a [ __ ]
correct get a those nikes okay get all
those nikes i come into your store i
know i could borrow 55 from
from i could borrow 75 dollars from
silent bob
to pay him 102 next week
so loan sharking that just becomes loan
shark 102 000 he has to pay next week
seven let's say 75 dollars he gives me
700 next week what if he doesn't have
100
i break his [ __ ] neck he can't his
wife his wife and him can't shop my
[ __ ] boat that i don't know better
make sure no it's just simplicity i'm
just making a point for libya what's the
big this is how you take over a [ __ ]
neighborhood this is how what the mafia
and all these other people have
forgotten that they have forgotten this
society when i was growing up there was
neighborhoods you went through you could
do anything like that you could buy a
[ __ ] bazooka and i could come to you
what's up dog what's up what are you
looking for i'm looking for a grandma
[ __ ] blow
who sent you down here felipe bro felipe
felipe from where what felipe fool
felipe boyle hi
boy oh [ __ ] you don't feel like you
haven't been his cousin right out of
this house no [ __ ] come on dog park your
car
in that neighborhood you can buy
anything
you can buy anything you know what what
do you want i want a [ __ ] ounce of
blow it's going to take an hour dog i
got to call my brother butchie you got
to go around the corner to the columbia
go to that bodega and wait there
what do you think you're doing that
bodega you put a bed in you buy a [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying i'm just saying i
don't know what the vigs are but that's
what the mafia lost
that neighborhood
and that neighborhood money
is a million dollars a year it's the
smallest percentage of but you can make
them more money
because there's no money it's like a car
dealerships if you have credit you come
in i get you a credit rate the whole
thing but if you got bad credit i could
have a good time with you dog i can make
you buy that insurance let's forget
about joey sanza you could forgot joey
sansa from godfather three they forgot
about his so do you understand what i'm
trying to say to you these people are
immigrants you take advantage of these
people
in many ways and i'm not just saying
immigrants this could be anything but a
black nation i saw it in poland i saw
where paul used to live they had a
corner every like every time i went
there were like three or four guys there
and at night they would tell it's funny
said bodega at night they would sell my
papooses right there right there you
know those are spots
those are [ __ ] spots that's what
that's called but it's amazing how once
the mob lost that listen the cops will
come 22 times and they'll break you up
out of the neighborhood come on guys you
got to break it up what are you guys
doing here reading the paper talking
about sports
you guys like hanging out in front of a
shoe store yeah that's what we do
eventually one day one cop's gonna go
guys what the [ __ ] and you're gonna go
dog what's it gonna cost to get you off
my back on this corner
and you know what if i'm making [ __ ]
30 000 [ __ ] weeks slinging [ __ ]
grams i'm gonna give you 500 600. it's
about that's what we lost in america you
know i always say that when i was a kid
i knew guys that weren't losers they
were just out of work they were college
students they would sell quaaludes
you bought [ __ ] 100 quail boots for
200 bucks you stole them for four
dollars
you made 200 on a thursday
you just waited til everybody got paid
everybody wanted a party
there's ways to sell drugs and there's
ways to be an animal both ways i'm not
i'm not saying that they're good
but i know that people get into binds in
their [ __ ] life
and sometimes you got to do what you got
to do you think those fools got too
corporate the mafia
they keep their here today they went for
bigger money and they left little
pennies
and for years they made money on the
little pennies
all of a sudden they got a house in
jersey how we don't need those pennies
no more i'm doing this but you know what
somebody else is going to take those
pennies and that's how they built power
those pennies
so now you have street gangs the kids
are 16 17. and we're getting the money
making money because they're slinging
that money was yours that you just let
it go
let it go if i had to guess it it must
be
harder to leave once you get in just
because you see how much money you make
drugs is such a [ __ ] huge part of our
society what do they call it pop culture
oh yeah drugs are pop culture
drugs are pop culture
every year there's a new fashion drug
every year people od
somebody's got to be pushing these
[ __ ] somebody got some mushrooms too
somebody got to be pushing these [ __ ]
drugs
you know it's uh what's up lee whatever
you know it's it's it's just interesting
and i had never thought about that
before
that like
there is always like when you watch
it right now when you watch narcos the
first time
you were like what the [ __ ] is how did
he make 65 million dollars a [ __ ] day
jesus when i was a kid that kid in aspen
that blew himself up in the jeep they
put a bomb in his jeep he went to st
every day he give somebody five hours go
let's start my car the one night he goes
to the aspen club he's lifting weights
by himself there's nobody there he goes
and starts the car poof a grenade under
the seat okay he had 31 days to uh
what's the book american
american sniper
american whatever
american whatever he says he killed the
guy the guy's name was steve grabo from
aspen colorado i was making six million
every six weeks didn't even do coke
didn't even see the coke didn't cut it
nothing all he was in charge was to go
going from miami to colorado to hawaii
and to minneapolis
he had two neighborhoods he controlled
hawaii in minneapolis see that's that
that's what i was talking about earlier
though
he only had two neighborhoods and it
gets [ __ ] blown up in the with a
grenade and car jeep but he was also
making
six million
every six weeks if you're making six
million every six weeks
[ __ ] you better check your sneakers for
grenades because i'm blowing you up
myself
you're following me under my bed you're
making six million every six weeks
you know you're part of something that's
just gigantic a fool when they go to you
what what are you i wasn't tell felipe
those two brothers from chicago those
fools were young all those drug dealers
that caused all that [ __ ] in chicago
that's why everybody's getting killed
and [ __ ]
although the two drug dealers in front
they're twins and they were the ones
that were moving all the cocaine for the
for the mexican cartel
and um
they um
they were the main the main drug dealers
out of chicago and they got arrested and
they're talking
yeah they turn state's evidence and [ __ ]
but that's why everybody's getting
murdered out there rightful yeah
it's caused all that [ __ ] shake of it
they were young [ __ ] after places
you guys drive by as stash houses
after places that you see that you're
like dog look at that place that place
is never busy
going in the back room you think they
got tomato paste back there they got 35
000 pounds of blow back they're waiting
to distribute to your neighborhood or
some other neighborhood there's a block
up here that i'm convinced almost every
store is that magnolia on the way into
burbank like we stopped by
one of those pet stores there's like one
thing on each corner
and they sold like four things in the
entire store and they're on magnolia and
then they they have two
no they have three halloween stores on
magnolia you know that donald trump
pinata
yes uh
it's [ __ ] crazy
so break down mexican independence for
me silent bob what happened tonight on
this particular thing
he that'll go right the screaming [ __ ]
don't look at him he don't know you know
this [ __ ] you're september 16th
before the revolution this is like late
1800s and um [ __ ] it was a priest
like a criollo right a [ __ ] light
skinned fool and he him [ __ ] uh
and what jose maria morellos and all
that [ __ ] they [ __ ] uh you know
started that [ __ ] that that uh
that that
march towards independence getting away
from the spanish crown and [ __ ] under
spanish control and actually becoming
mexico
a country in and of itself
you know and [ __ ] you know what was
all the way up here and [ __ ] so four
years of college is all you got yeah
what do you [ __ ] know i thought
you're going to break it down for me to
see i gave you this like [ __ ] dude i
haven't that [ __ ] course in days did
you major in mexican
he's gonna be a [ __ ] attorney that
means his major was history those were
the uh the roots of uh pretty much
mexican independence and then uh
resulted in the 1910 mexican revolution
dude so the mexican revolution was fifth
of adventure 1910.
cinco de mayo that's a struggle because
it's a the battle sequel the battle of
puebla were
2500
mexican
farmers with islamists with rakes
and leaf blowers beat the [ __ ] out of
the french
it's [ __ ] up that it's mexican
independence and it's a jew week too
it's rosh hashanah
wasn't a [ __ ] salvadorian
independence day yesterday
yeah
i think i'm i think i'm um
hispanic week is all mexican independent
days september the month right
heritage hispanic heritage month from
hispania and nobody knows you know they
make up things it's the [ __ ] weirdest
thing bro it's like half the menu on
taco bell is not mexican mexicans don't
even know what the [ __ ] they are but
that's the same with chinese food when
you talk to chinese people like [ __ ] the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] eat is not the
[ __ ] garbage i don't mess with no uh
mandarine chinese food
steve simone didn't like it as much he
went to china i like american chinese
food better
my my favorite chinese from the hunan
dynasty what's that [ __ ] that's what
we're [ __ ] raised up no we're raised
on uh
american chinese food with the mustard
and the
province you know
what you're thinking about [ __ ] up
what's the matter with you nothing
everything all right i know the thing
about orange chicken what you looking
good what do you eat when you go to
chinese restaurants now now
now that i'm vegan i just eat um
the noodles
the noodles by themselves
plain noodles
that little star kicking in the little
jewelry store
joey didn't get the
weight loss surgery because he couldn't
eat chinese food and now you're saying
that all you just plain noodles that's
all i eat man they're good dude
or sometimes you know i i i ordered the
um
i love thai food bro like like the um
yellow curry green curry red curry with
brown rice man that's just down
or the dessert uh the sticky rice and
mango is so good
you gotta try it joe diaz all right
yeah i'll be down there tomorrow
hell yeah man i'll make you some vegan
pork tartas tortas
you know uh there's an elephant in the
room
it's it's weird because we have to talk
about this
especially if we're doing this podcast
something really weird happened today i
woke up to some
wild [ __ ] you know willie barceta
sometimes you uh
you know you wake up in the morning
expect them to have a weird day you read
something you're like what
you know the big news today was about
steve running as easy you know yeah man
and uh
i learned how to spell his name
correctly today what the [ __ ] happens
when you uh
you know when you get caught in
something
you know it's
i'm not mad at the guy you know i don't
know
i've known him for 20 years since he
came out here whenever he said he came
out here i've never had a problem with
him he's always stuck up for me you know
he always said hello to me and then you
always read you read this and you go
what the [ __ ] i got a couple emails like
did you see this like i'm supposed to
call him an [ __ ] whatever hey man
i've been there that's why i tell people
be careful what you get yourself
involved into
you know i didn't i didn't tell my
mother i got left back
i was gonna say like do you guys i i
used to love to lie i like about crazy
things
like and like shot and like do all that
stuff
so like
obviously it's not excusable but
what if like he just it just got bigger
and bigger and
but then he said it on marin
so that's not good
but i don't i don't know if you can call
him a bad person just for one thing
we've all [ __ ] told a lot
it was to a certain age i lied to him i
[ __ ] up my leg one time man i was
running from the cops
and i'm and i wasn't running i was
running from the cops because i thought
they were like coming after me but they
just turned the lights on and went go
chase somebody else so me being paranoid
i ran and i fell in a ditch
and then i was crawling all the way home
and i remember telling my friends i got
jumped by these three nazis bro
fighting for the cause i catch up on
these three [ __ ] skinheads bro
and they're really bro they jumped you
yeah man [ __ ] and then they're live i
[ __ ] your life like a [ __ ] lie like
it was embarrassing i mean we all
[ __ ] lie [ __ ] embarrassing
we're gonna eat that brownie i think i'm
over there mr lebowski over there
trying to eat the brownie of death
listen man i used to lie
oh my god i was living in a [ __ ] lie
so i was like 20 once i went to jail i'm
like you know what man
i see how these guys lie fake as you
make it like once when you once you once
you go to [ __ ] jail
you see these guys with broken down
socks nobody visits them and they're
telling you how they were pimp on the
outside though i had tons of money i had
millions of [ __ ] nobody's [ __ ]
dancing
you got no tv
you know when you got no tv in your
[ __ ] room there's got to be a problem
you split that one
he likes trouble i'm beyond good
yeah like a [ __ ] beyonder
so [ __ ] granny
i didn't even know that um
he was um
from new york
and then and then apparently like he got
his girlfriend
up in it like he said she was working
there too and maybe she wasn't
that's like it's scary like it's scared
now you have to think about what you say
he had it all planned out back
because he had like his his career he
just got that buffalo wild wings thing
and
am i gonna his new specials coming out
and sam
you do here we do like buffalo hot wings
how could he not
buffalo wild wings i'll take his his job
and who put that fool on blast who let
everybody know that full light or how
did you talk about the new york times
something about they confronted them or
something they checked the [ __ ] fact
you know
it's funny because uh
about
11 years now
about 15 years ago
i was a little misunderstanding
with my ex-wife
and one day we were talking about
something
and she goes uh
you know
i read your resume by the way you're
lying you weren't born in cuba you were
born in new york city i read your birth
certificate i go which one did you read
you know
it was a black and white one that nobody
ever read that i lost that bla i've lost
that just from being a kid no wallet
that one had a van a cube on it the
whole thing when i got the redone it
says new york city the re one of the
reasons why i'm scared i know i won't
get a passport is it's gonna open up a
bag of worms they're not gonna find me
in there my wife is a gentile
okay all you gotta do is open my wife's
brain up without weed and you're done
she went on ancestry.com
i don't have an ancestor on that
[ __ ] do you understand me
there ain't no nothing like none of my
people came through [ __ ] it was lost
it was probably lost during 9 11
in the record
listen during the [ __ ] there ain't a
[ __ ] record
there ain't a [ __ ] wreck it was lost
in that lie
but my uncle's in there my uncle's in
there from glendale
my uh
twig on that bridge yeah no no no no
stop
a little [ __ ] stub it's [ __ ]
amazing bro it's [ __ ] really amazing
that
so i know that you know but that's the
only thing somebody could jam me up on
they say well you burst this guy
actually
he's not really
really [ __ ]
and then i'm gonna have a problem
because open up a [ __ ] can of [ __ ]
worms
do people accuse you of lying a lot all
the time
[ __ ] let it [ __ ] something wouldn't
they why wouldn't they but you know i
have a friend of mine that listens to
this show
i have a a a friend they call you on
that [ __ ] how do they no i have old
school friends who listen no i have a
friend of mine that i bumped into in
texas
and about two years and then about a
year ago he hit me up with an email that
he goes do me a favor and say hello to
my son
because he doesn't believe that i grew
up like you know because he used to tell
him these type of stories and some would
go
dad stop it
so one day the kid went to him and said
you know this joey diaz guy he's saying
this [ __ ] he goes yeah i grew up with
the guy he goes say hello let him know
we're friends
now the kid believes his father
for years let me tell you something for
years i didn't say any of these stories
not because i didn't want to say it was
because i didn't think nobody would
believe them or and i also believe that
everybody else lived like that
i thought that everybody broke windows
when they were kids everybody had a fun
[ __ ] life it's not until i went to
colorado that i would talk to people and
i would tell them [ __ ] and they would
just look at me dogs
and i'd say i'm never telling that story
again because obviously you can't tell
that type of [ __ ] people don't
understand that the rest of the country
was until this podcast [ __ ] but i said
[ __ ] i gotta let this stuff go
i can't live with this stuff this
stuff's hilarious bugging a hooker
nobody's ever mugged the hooker and
taking it back to jersey and those kids
are still alive and they come to my
[ __ ] shows the kid that drove that
night still comes to all the shows and
hugs me and he goes oh my nephews love
when you tell them my name and all this
[ __ ]
but there's people who are going to turn
out about you and tony hawk hanging out
when you were little really
my brother angel lied he thought con
artist bro he's a liar
he would lie to my my son and my little
nephews one day and said that he used to
hang out with tony hawk when he was 14
years old because they were about the
same age and then one day we're having a
conversation and my son jumps into the
conversation my dad does tony hawk
and he goes oh if i do
and i said no
your uncle angel's a liar i was like you
never told me that food
i never understood listen okay
me and lee go out
okay we buy a grandma blow
so we bump into two ugly fat chicks
they suck our dick we piss on them
we take them to a hotel and what the
[ __ ] is this don't worry about it we
take them to a hotel these definitely
we're gonna lie and say they're hot they
wake up the next day
they throw us out of the hotel we don't
have enough money to pay for the hotel
that's the story me and lee go giggle
when you bump into me two years from now
[ __ ] brother trust me joke we're
comedians what do we say we went out we
had an eight ball we bumped into two of
the hottest chicks
that's how you dance
back to a holiday inn oh you should know
what rodrigo if you tell me that or
felipe
that's okay
that's okay though you know
you did get your dick sucked you know
whether you were pretty it's for the
judge or whatever sometimes you pick up
an ugly chick you know whatever but
things are happening in your life
whatever
that's but for me to i used to have i
had two situations in my life i never i
used to have a friend that owned the
deli
that dog
i could go up to the next morning he
would be like
i was out with felipe last night but we
partied out until six in the morning
with richard gere and oh my god and
elise ayat was there and oh my god it
was [ __ ] amazing then
a week late i bumped into philippengo
what's up dog dog what happened that
night you went out with [ __ ] silent
bob you said you were too sick silent
bomb i haven't seen silent bomb in a
year
i had one of those [ __ ] oh that
would just
you know
and you'd sit there and go
why would somebody say that
but you knew if you went back and you
you weren't going to win the argument
i said the time before i didn't say him
i said he was one of those dudes
he was he just and then i grew up with
this girl way before you guys were
around chachi member chachi scarpeo
scott bail
this girl in high school
just made up a story that
she was dating scott baio
doug this went on for like two years
taught a girl
every [ __ ] monday
wow
we boy i'm dating scott baio and she
would have pictures
of her
which got bail but with 20 other people
and scott bear was on the other side of
the room and she'd be on this side of
the room
and she told me how oh no no he doesn't
want us to know anybody to know that
we're dating
we're going to the junior prom together
and [ __ ]
and junior prompt came and she came with
some fat dude with pimples
i never called her on it because why
would you make that up
you have to feel bad on your own just
just walking around and thinking that
your back crack gun
you have to feel bad just thinking that
your mind that likes right or wrong you
have to think that you feel bad just
thinking that you said that a lot
that scott baio's gonna come to your
[ __ ] wedding i remember
i remember man i lied to my mom
i know that i liked my mom i liked my
mom a bunch of times
no i lied to my dad
oh yeah i know i think i lied because i
messed up my hand somehow outside
somewhere and i told my dad that i
messed up my hand trying to catch a home
run at dodger stadium
is that what you were working on
when i was a kid because i had like this
blood this purple thing on my hand and i
didn't know how it got there right i
have this purple
bruise permanent brood on my hand
so one time my dad asked me why do you
have that there and i must have bumped
into something i said no i was trying to
catch this baseball dodger stadium right
now and we were both there
and never felt bad because i lied to him
i never told him the truth i lied
i feel so bad now about my mom i told
her so many lies growing up
i told my stepdad well i tried telling
him lies that [ __ ] was a lie
detector
that dude was just a [ __ ] lie
detector
like i said all those years i just lied
my way through them i'm gonna get money
on friday i'm waiting for this i'm
waiting for that
they were just [ __ ] lies man
i'm happy i stopped that [ __ ] but when
you're wheeling dealing it's okay to lie
it's when you lie to your friends about
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] you know you only
wanna have to lie them before
you know
i lie sometimes two of us said yeah man
you said well you had a great set bro
your set was killer bro i'm surprised
you didn't they didn't sign you
it's harmony because you have to
remember them like you have like if you
lie to everybody have to like remember
all the lies it must be hard to like
keep straight i would have been nervous
walking around firemen
you know it's funny i was on marin
and i told the story on marion this is
and this is the type of [ __ ] that people
are just you know
i told the story on marin i was very
fortunate when i was a young man i
wanted to learn how to do so many weird
things
and when i moved to aspen i met a guy i
met a chick and her husband
was this [ __ ] closet killer don't be
lying
and all this guy did was we became
friends and after a while he showed me
his weapons
and then after a while he showed me how
to shoot i would spend the friday night
with that the ice cream guy no this is
uh just a regular white dude that was a
great guy big [ __ ] vietnam bad
train the whole [ __ ] thing and he'd
take me to the mountains and i paid for
bullets
and he let me shoot his gun they teach
me how to shoot him from angles and [ __ ]
and one day the guy trusted me and he
goes listen doug
i really want to rob the bank of aspen
i've got these plans he took me the
[ __ ] lunch and he came out with
the most detailed [ __ ] plan of
blueprints and [ __ ] everything how long
have you been planning it for a year and
a half before he met me he just needed
guys
and his plan was to rob
the bank of aspen
christmas eve
you know when you tell them a story
okay
and you're just excited that you're
telling the story yeah
i said when i told the story i go we
were going to rob the bank on christmas
day
oh my god i got 50 people that are
calling me a liar because the banks are
closed on christmas
day so do you understand me what you got
to deal with any way you put it
we deal with this there's people here
there's people they said christmas eve
right but i in the rush of the story i
said we're gonna rob me christmas day
you know
banks are closed on christmas day it was
[ __ ] [ __ ]
presidency you know
people will scrutinize no matter what
but for me to make up something i don't
gain from it bro well they're like they
can't
listen not to interrupt you let me tell
you something i'm going to tell you
something you know i love you they don't
have to interrupt you let me tell you
something i forgot more good [ __ ]
stories
than the stories i remember i did drugs
for 30 years i've forgotten [ __ ] good
stories
i'm going to go home next week and might
bump into my friends and they pull me
over and they'll go the last time i saw
you
between you and i some of them could be
[ __ ] because i don't remember it at
all
but some of them i catch it and i start
thinking about going oh [ __ ] i did eat
yeah i remember i learned something a
friend of mine i really don't know that
guy man but he tells me what's up
everything yeah i'm a goofy friend and
we're all fans of this movie a goofy
friend of mine gave me a book in miami
one time and it was the book by
and it made a lot of sense to me it was
the book by uh henry hill's daughter
she wrote a book what's it called who
the [ __ ] knows my father's a bump
she wrote this [ __ ] book
you know just not saying that he was a
liar but saying that he was like [ __ ]
a bum
he was high how does he almost cause a
lot of problems because she's like how
does he
you know remember half this [ __ ] if he
was high and she told her side of the
story like the the funniest thing ever
that's funny does that that movie they
stole it was that in real life he was
living with karen in seattle washington
and one day he went and did something
met some chick married her and brought
her back to seattle washington to renton
and lived with karen and his new wife
and when karen asked him are you [ __ ]
crazy because no no don't worry about it
i married him my other name
that's the line that steve
martin had and when he calls the
detective in the [ __ ] room and he
goes i'm in vegas say hello to my wife
yeah and he goes you're not supposed to
[ __ ] get married he goes don't worry
i married under my new wife henry hill
really did that
he really married a chick and brought
her home and said listen i'm married to
you as henry hill i'm married to her as
mario andretti
that's how [ __ ] crazy
this guy was so she goes this is how
crazy he was you're really gonna believe
his story
you know
it's like when you do coke i love doing
coke but you know what the [ __ ]
hardest thing about doing coke was four
in the morning if you cook with somebody
who wasn't going to suck your dick
that means they're going to tell you
their story
and that's our signature we all have
every hooker has a [ __ ] story and
we're all [ __ ] hookers and we all
translate it from our point of view
you know what i'm saying somebody else
might tell my story and tell them how
dirty and a disgusting [ __ ] human
being i was which is [ __ ] true
you know i'm telling you i always tell
people you have no [ __ ] idea but
they're like no we like you joey okay
but uh
it's just weird because we tell them i
remember getting high with people and
they break down at four in the morning
and tell me how their parents molested
them and [ __ ]
you know and how they don't buzz kill oh
my god tremendous buzzkill remember the
power
dog
oh my god we're we're going to work at
the improv we're getting high with some
guy in tampa
he worked for the improv but he didn't
work there no more some fat kid
who looked like canelo the boxer you
know but if he was like 500 pounds and
we're smoking weed with this guy and
then his friend shows up
you know his other friend they're there
with us and he starts telling us that
his other friend that's not there raped
his little sister
and i'm like damn
and i'm gonna tell you something i love
you to death i know you for 20 years so
i'll tell you this with all due respect
you're a lunatic magnet
if they're lunatics you attract them
every city
and you encourage these [ __ ] lunatics
you make them pick you up and go to
lunch with these savages
with 16 people they're like hi we want
to take it to our home d dinner philippe
came over listen philippe is to a
different level
i don't go home with people eat [ __ ]
lunch you're a [ __ ] lunatic i know
about i'm in odessa i'm in odessa texas
and the owner of the club will felipe
you want to go to some fights sure man
let's go halfway there what kind of
fights are these man dogfights will make
you drop me off i don't want to go
felipe and he takes the ride and he lets
him pick him up and he hangs out with
them and then he gives them your number
hey bro i'm with this guy dog he picked
me up at the airport he loves this house
eating it's [ __ ] crazy
you let you mingle with these [ __ ]
people sure they're buzz kills i spot
them i see them with that they try to
get them right away oh dog they try to
because
i like when you notice him you start
your head starts nodding you start
talking fast and you pick up your phone
and you gotta go
listen doug first of all i'm deaf
i'm legally deaf
so if it's you and and noise in the room
i'm here like last night we're having a
conversation with the nicest guy in the
world i heard nothing
i was looking at you you're over there
bowing turning red in the face from how
high
he has i don't hear nothing so when you
see my head bowing and you continue like
i know if i'm talking to somebody what's
going on if i come up to you i'm like hi
you know my name is kyle i'm a big fan
and i'm looking at you know you have
like this weird confused look on your
face
i know i'm walking the [ __ ] away from
you i caught you at a bad time are you
welcome to that comedian from houston
joey i made fifty thousand dollars last
month i made twenty thousand this month
which one remember um that guy from
houston he'll tell you that he made
fifty thousand last night signing dvds
working for mercia now i wanna borrow a
thousand dollars
it's like when you're in jail that's how
much money i got paper everywhere don't
let me get some cigarettes and [ __ ] i'll
hook you up next weekend why do you
gotta [ __ ] lie to me
no you meet felipe i
tried every lunatic there is out there
but not only does he attract them
because duncan has the same power
duncan's people come and they they walk
in and they got big eyes and they're
like can i talk to you for a second i
had this vision listen let me talk to
you later on all right here's a joint go
in the corner and smoke it
step on the street by the bus there i'll
be right out there's some lunatics out
there
but in the world of lunacy
nobody attracts them and keeps them
around
like felipe
felipe gives lunatics like gasoline like
he gives him a hope to live till next
time
let's not be back in the years [ __ ]
don't cry you hold on don't kill
yourself don't shoot your mother
i'll be back speed your bird bird man
and then they'll show up to the shows
and go i'm friends with felipe
and you're like listen i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on but i can't do what
was
some one night there was a friend of you
or somewhere that tormented me
this had to be around a year ago san
jose no no no no no no
no this was somewhere else spanish guy
he tormented me
he bought tickets for the boat show he's
probably listening right now michael
myers girl michael myers all from
houston food nah houston got a lot of
[ __ ] lunatics dawg
back in the day mina felipe
used to have some good [ __ ] times in
houston texas listen
i loved it i i tell you if i could i
don't give a [ __ ] about drugs
i was born to do drugs
i was born to get my dick sucked and get
freaky and get horned up and look out
windows
it was a horrible time in my life but
then again i [ __ ] loved it will i do
it again now i would never get high
again
i don't want to know what that feels
like ever again that was just crazy
and i saw this guy in his worst time and
he saw me in my [ __ ] all-time worst
time so
what's up with you [ __ ] are you ready
for another edible did you eat a piece
of chocolate no why not when then you
gotta eat a stock because they had three
strawberries are [ __ ] we all like
who gives a [ __ ] what's up
you're not done you're not done until
the show's over crazy so pick something
you want to style a piece of chocolate
which one you know neither
a half a star that starts pretty strong
man yeah it is that way you think i eat
them called water because that's for the
first 30 minutes i'm just still here
listening to you you want to start you
want another one i'm good with that star
man
i got the star of david in my art all
right all right so you got to eat this
[ __ ] it's wednesday night it's mexican
independence how dare your girlfriend's
mexican correct
yes and how dare you sit down and bump
on like you're gonna pick her up after
this no what what is wrong with you
because she lives with her mother and
i'm high as [ __ ]
you beat the horn tell her come down
you've never seen one side story go over
there and beat the [ __ ] horn and do
what
come over let's go back to my house and
celebrate mexican independence within me
being this high who gives a [ __ ] give it
two stars and make it catch up
what's wrong with you i'm giving you all
these ideas here you go you you figure
out how to get a little taste before you
go to las vegas and you're acting like a
half a fighter we're gonna have lunch
tomorrow what you know lunch what's
lunch that's 40 out of your pocket and
you don't know
she's coming over she's coming off for
sure yes what's she making i don't know
he said i gotta deal with he's worse
than you with the vegan [ __ ]
i got a vegan and a [ __ ] jew that
don't know what her mind her mom is a
little bit upset with you felipe why
because because she saw you on
platininto the more like that yeah
and paula told her that you're vegan and
she goes no
you think it's very upsetting
no
no no i'm still upset he's a [ __ ]
vegan we used to have fun with you steve
me
you get taken to places and he's a
[ __ ] vegan he's eating olive oil off
his fingers and [ __ ]
i need that [ __ ] i was telling rodrigo
about that restaurant right next to the
hotel you always eat the donut the donut
shop shims
shrimpies shrimps chickpeas
chip please
shrimp the hot dog the hot dog bun
it's like a hot houston by the freeway
shrimp please
across the street from the old house
like
it's in houston
it's a donor shop only like a breakfast
sausage wrapped in a hockey what are you
confusing me for look it up there's a
certain thing there's a certain name for
that
but they they have them in a lot of
places
i forget what the paoli's something like
that the sausage and the thing i used to
go by the last stop up the corner by the
old houston livestock they used to make
the best jalapeno ones oh my god
all crunchy i said a dozen of those
[ __ ] things with two cans of coke
for breakfast i do coke till six in the
morning pistol pete
would drive me whatever house pistol
pete would drive me over i got a dozen
of those things and two cans of coke
though or if not we go to the place down
waste gray
that the breakfast place that the guy
owned with the greek guy that hated
everybody
that would tell you to hurry up in order
what do you want to order
hey i don't know what do you have hurry
up i know all that tabby up i don't have
time for this [ __ ]
and white people would run the [ __ ] out
of there
what the [ __ ] are those things in
houston again i always eat them i just
had them when i was down there
deliciously taquitos
what should i search
oh
[ __ ] shrimp please i picked up shrimp
please
i don't [ __ ] know don't make me call
people i always forget [ __ ]
anyway no no they haven't been a lot of
play i only did the houston improv twice
i did the old one once and this one this
last buck at a time
yeah no no no
that's the play i didn't even like they
had the
schripply's donuts yeah yeah what do
they have
what's in that place what's that's a
place yeah peyotes what's it called
shipley donuts i know but there's
something like a hot dog what's the name
yeah it's a sausage
okay
that's a weird name yeah like a cannoli
framboli
i don't think they have their [ __ ]
manual
hold on wait i'll look for the it's not
on their website hold on yes i forget
what the [ __ ] the name is what's going
on with you
what are you doing next what are you
shooting your next special oh man i hope
you i'll shoot my next special this year
sometime in december where we're at um
we don't know yet
how many specials have you shot just one
column cheese
kolaches
what's in them kolachi factory shipley
right there kalachi factory you know but
shipley's is a place that sells kolaches
yeah but everybody sells kolaches but
there's a place called the kalachi
factory that's really good and they have
they call them
ones
or polish i don't [ __ ] know they got
uh sausage and cheese jalapeno and
cheese
plain sausage
jalapeno sausage and juice
ham and cheese
sausage and cheese
and pulled pork it's cool stuff man i
don't eat pulled pork on the outside you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're eating
it says pulled pork everyone loves
pulled pork i i tried i like it every
once a year i try to eat it and it's
always terrible if you're gonna eat pork
pork get either a place that specializes
pulled pork yes when you tell me you
went to subway and got the pork sandwich
i feel [ __ ] bad for you when you tell
me you went to some white joint and got
the pulled pork that's who eats pulled
pork in l.a that's why nobody eats
[ __ ] sparabs in california because
you can't sell them enough nobody eats
[ __ ] sparabs you go to eat in jersey
that's the first thing you don't let me
get a small load of hair grid pork fried
rice and [ __ ] egg drop soup
nobody eats pork out here dog so you
gotta go you want pulled pork you gotta
go to a place they can grab like grand
central market in downtown l.a you're
gonna find that chubby greasy looking
mexican dude that's wearing like a a
butcher shirt
and an oldest dog a dodger hat with no
head but no no head back nothing in the
back you know what's the name of that
street in downtown grand central market
on broadway no
like it's a mexican street oliveira
street oh barrel street now there's that
that was fun they got some good flowers
it was creepy it was like some of them
were like like the like leather store
they like oh just like i had a store
just of like the hat the masks for the
wrestlers
there's a cool place did you get a
little wrestling match
no i was i was going to see if you have
a wrestling match you could go by
ballers tonight
and just kick the [ __ ] door down and
tell them you hear the sling dick and
they they're from mexican traditions the
only white people these people know
you gotta go over there and boss them
around tell them you're the boss here
you're the captain kirk of the
enterprise and [ __ ] yeah okay go take
the daughter home with you tonight
you're gonna leave paul at home alone
right from here go over that beep the
horn
yo adrian come down
just hard bro play something
no women like that
if you call paula you text baller right
now put on something sexy i'm coming
against you [ __ ]
she'll be ready for papa and [ __ ] you
just dictated the evening but you're
sitting there like a hat
you don't know
no because i know women and every woman
likes to feel special and hot right now
she's thinking she's going to bed you
got to write or not i'm going to suck
your [ __ ] [ __ ] you've got to send
her to class tomorrow
what time is class tomorrow
three you believe this is what i deal
with
three a.m three in the afternoon
so how long does it take to get ready
for class 10 minutes
call her up right now tell her you're
picking it up tonight to wear some silky
panties [ __ ] [ __ ] you bring it to
you bring it [ __ ]
your house wake up in the morning you
take off for breakfast nice then you
[ __ ] drop her off and get the whole
day you gotta [ __ ] with her at lunch
time till three you got [ __ ] going on
you gotta make a living you gotta if you
pick her up tonight you guarantee the
pizza ass you're guaranteed another
pizza ass for breakfast then you take it
at denny's you give it three pieces of
bacon some pancakes you get her building
back up her caloric intake and her
protein from the stabbing the juice dick
gave her and it's all over you
understand me you drop her ass off and
you got a [ __ ] jiu jitsu that's it
that's how you do it you're gonna waste
your time and pick up tomorrow and drop
40 and you're not going to get no choice
you know you're not getting charged in
the moment
where you want to go and let's go let's
go to the thai place like a [ __ ] half
a fruit cake tonight she got nowhere to
go every avenue she turns to this dick
every avenue around she's like pat
bennett on that video i'm coming around
the corner there's dick everywhere you
pick her up tonight beep the horns
she'll come down you take her home
you eat some popcorn whatever the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you eat at night and you give her
that [ __ ] stomach yeah from lee by
lee israeli dick
then you wake up in the morning before
she knows what's going on hi
another [ __ ] stabbing come on you get
up you wash your helmet you take care of
yourself you tell her get up and you
think of the denny's and you get two
grand slams you get four items for
whatever the [ __ ] who's better than my
bro come on huh
what do you think felipe this guy wants
to wait go home lonely tonight you're
all horned up you did thc you got a
little nut bag right now
you gotta go pick her up man whack off
by yourself like a [ __ ] momo you
gotta go pick her up man bring her home
and wash her feet glasses
i can see if i can
be nine
classes at three
go grab this thing by the [ __ ] horns
will you he has a pointless
seriously you gotta [ __ ] grab this by
all the [ __ ] horses
you don't know paul it won't tell her
who the [ __ ] lee is
burn some cinnamon inside the oven bro
y'all tell her who the [ __ ] lee is
telling you picking up me to stop by yum
yum donuts you gotta lure these
[ __ ] what if you were a
pedophile you just show up with a van no
you gotta have movies and [ __ ]
fishing lines and toys taught her to
make your kolache ice cream same thing
the [ __ ] is wrong give her the
you
collage
you don't know paula i know paula show
up with some ice packs
come down she'll [ __ ] come down she's
starving right now ain't nothing to eat
in that [ __ ] house
she's starving right now it's 10 o'clock
at [ __ ] night you don't know
you [ __ ] momo
she go to the gym today yeah yeah she's
[ __ ] starving right now yeah they got
lettuce and fruit sticks but let me tell
you something
you show up with three chocolate yum yum
donuts and a [ __ ] bikini on
with a little half a pint of that
[ __ ] diet ice cream you like tell me
she's gonna stay upstairsly
are you [ __ ] see what i'm saying
i gotta take you from having an a to
have new z every [ __ ] week on a
different topic
but did you go on a date
that's what i heard he signed up for
[ __ ] mexicanheritage.com
he picked up a nice message
he bones and thugs in harmony
go ahead text it we'll talk over here
text to tell you getting donuts
tell her it's doughnuts and dick knight
police say yeah residents just like that
tell her about the egg player tower you
want to get excited i gotta tell her you
have a surprise for it so it keeps her
on tune
and then take a picture of your dick
right before you pick up a uh
and go to yum yum donuts and tell her
it's dick and donut night at the casa
[ __ ]
sciatica you know what i'm saying that
sounds like a song dick and donut
ducking down at night that's it lee you
got to start breaking this [ __ ] down you
walk around on ice cubes around and then
she might get mad
she's not going to get mad but well she
does she don't have class until three in
the afternoon
she wants to sit there like a victim
with her mom
i want to go i don't know right now tell
me you wouldn't want to eat something
and then eat her ass tonight
tell me the truth you don't want to get
a little stabbing
i would but i also kind of wanted to
just go home and do what sit there and
want to eat pepperoni sandwiches by
yourself like a [ __ ] charles brown
are you telling me every time you get
high you want to go home and and deal
with all that
my wife's sleeping i'm in no danger
nobody's 46 years old with a
two-year-old i can't wake my wife up
with a million dollars to give me a
stabbing but you you're a 26 year old
man when i was 26 you think i i want to
go home you are your toilet of your life
it's amazing how people always say you
know
i wish i was 26 or whatever these guys i
don't wish i'm 26. i just want the
opportunities that the uh you know
for them to understand at 26 you're not
married to not she lives with her mother
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want at
this point right now this is your
[ __ ] world
you call her up right now this is what
26 year olds do i never i'm wearing this
here tomorrow who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ]
tomorrow everything changes this is how
your world is it all changes you got to
keep on always shaving that [ __ ] keep
it tight she's probably at home right
now [ __ ] farting in it and [ __ ]
farting backwards in pajamas it's going
into a [ __ ] it's fermenting it smells
like burrito juice and sweat from the
gym but if you call up right now and say
look i have some donuts for you and some
dick take a shower and watch that
[ __ ] monkey it's all over the chat
she will never sit like that again
because you always keep her on [ __ ]
whatever what about tomorrow what about
them i got business tomorrow i gotta
break the routine tomorrow's my last day
here i got no time for romance
i gotta leave at eight o'clock i'm gonna
hook up with you for five six hours i
got no time for five or six hours let me
give you a stab in tonight tomorrow we
got breakfast and then um you go your
way i go mine and everybody's happy
that's how pimp moves his hand you say i
gotta deal with dog
you're crazy
hell yeah what's up felipe what's up
fool i can't call it what are you gonna
give up this vegan [ __ ] eat a taco i
don't know man we need you to taco break
it down doug it's over
no more vegan [ __ ] nothing's happened
i'm doing good man why do you become a
vegan for what to do what this you know
[ __ ] well but you've always liked
[ __ ] meat always man okay call her up
texas tell you
it's over you got that jew dick on
[ __ ]
i'm holding on fire and [ __ ] she knows
she knows nothing you say i live with
dog
well he gets mad at me he's like happy
i'm not mad at you you know i'm right
i'm just trying to get you the right
thing economically
and [ __ ] fist the whole thing had to
drive all the way back and forth to bed
now she likes the bus
you said she likes the bus she likes
walking around perfect midnight take the
bus gives a [ __ ] take a chance columbus
dish that'll be one story charles
there's a vigilante out there guarding
the streets
she could uberate over here that's right
uber there you go you have to imagine
that
over there like a pimp that's what
that's
real 26 year old does he sends okra
player bro and you can tell them listen
there's an extra ten in there you gotta
make sure you make sure you show up with
the [ __ ] macarena you got a man like
you're gonna think like um like sam
kittenson said or i don't know i'm never
gonna be the best but i gotta ruin it
for the next guy
so you gotta be better than the next guy
not better than the last guy [ __ ] the
last guy the last guy's gone you gotta
better be better than the next guy
what's wrong with you looking at me on
paranoid phone all scared what's going
on with you
what do you know what's going on with
you you gave me 375 milligrams why do
you count the milligrams do you see me
counting
counting milligrams is like dropping
names you just say i ate a bunch of
[ __ ] things and got high watch with
the dropping names i hate 390 i deserve
credit for what i eat the [ __ ] credit
credit is in your eyeballs show me
eyeballs that's where the [ __ ] credit
is right they can't see my eyeballs let
me give some shout outs here i got no
glasses so if i [ __ ] it up i'm sorry
wait till dusk you know i love you
[ __ ]
kayla
sheldon i love you too
i don't know see what happens no [ __ ]
glasses
nolan
raoul herrera you know i love you bobby
sharon with the [ __ ] t-shirts and
crystal i love you greg powers and lin
stay black thank you
th3
h1 jh i love you too
and uh
dinah mateo you know i love you too you
little sexy asian savage over there on
facebook
i'm trying bro i can't see without my
glasses i thought i left them in the car
when i went in the car they weren't in
there i got my backups but i'm not going
down and i get them you know what i'm
saying but these guys got here
before i could get the party started
i'm shooting my first special this week
in vegas i don't know how i'm gonna do
it felipe i have no idea what i'm doing
i have a little bit of confidence in it
i'm just gonna go up there and go
[ __ ] crazy that's it i don't give a
[ __ ] netflix but i don't give a [ __ ]
you understand me i'm going this is for
me and my main man
the flying jew how was your show at the
ice house
not good the run through the run through
listen there wasn't in my world there's
no run through you think that you're
gonna run through and then you get there
and something else [ __ ] happens and
you take it a different direction
so there's no run through i have an idea
what i'm doing
i have an idea of the order i want to do
and then i got to tell a story but i'm
excited i'm just doing it to do this
[ __ ] you just gotta do it and sometimes
you gotta do it out of your pocket to
see what it's really like and that's
what i'm doing i'm taking a [ __ ]
chance columbus did so
i've had to do everything you know like
i called lydia a night after i dropped
him off i
i broke it down to lee what's going to
happen what we're going to hear and
what's going to happen
you know there's always in the 15 18 17
years i've been here
there's always somebody pulling my
string at the end they tell you the
[ __ ] truth the best i've done is when
i've taken this into my own hands
and i've imploded my [ __ ]
philosophies and my street philosophies
with what the same [ __ ] they're telling
me that's the best i've ever done out of
it but these people are giving you
advice they don't know dick
they don't know dick you know it's like
a stock broker he could tell you
whatever the [ __ ] he wants from reading
charts it's at the end of the weekend
sweet
it's what you bring to the [ __ ] table
you know what i'm saying
i'm never going back to georgia
what's so full i have a web series bro i
wrote me and my wife we have a web
series
probably going to start over let me ask
you this so if you sell this web series
you're going to still give it credit oh
yeah okay look at you here on this
[ __ ] engine you believe this little
producer credit a producer and writer
credit maybe look at that yeah looks
like i got lisa and i got i'm gonna
bubble stuff i don't know what he's
getting
well he's getting give a little shout
out give him a first a d credit i don't
know yet yeah
triple hd triple h triple o g i like it
and when does the web series start
october 5th is called the shop
it's about um me working at the at my um
weed dispensary and this just shot
we shot it all in green screen but
everything it looks pretty good
um
rodrigo is in it yeah man we have a
bunch of um chris thoren he's my
sidekick
and we just um
we just it's like the office was shot in
the dispensary
so
all you and me dealing with customers
every day selling pot
selling um you know medicine for people
and dealing with regular stuff the so
it's a short web series it's only like
two minutes long every episode is only
like two minutes long how many episodes
did you do seven look at your half a
season half a season baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] around what's up lee
well felipe like finance the first thing
we did
oh one of the first things we did was
the documentary executive executive
executive producer that's right
what's up fool now how many years later
look he's still doing his thing yeah man
and i'm gonna be in um denver next week
the comedy works
headline in there for the first time
playboy can you go back there yeah i was
just there they stole me are you a badge
of seattle
no seattle's off limits i'm trying to
um i'm trying to see
even if i get the warren and seattle off
what
are my options in canada
are they still gonna say no i'm not
gonna pay a bunch of money go to seattle
warren down then they're gonna tell me
no for canada and my passport for cuba
and i spent that money i really listen
it's not that i hate seattle
it's not anything like that i'm the type
of guy bro then once you move forward
you don't go back
that's it seattle me it just didn't work
out man
i if i tell you the five arrests that i
got arrested for in seattle you'll sit
there and go joey how'd this happen
jaywalking
uh a stolen car
domestic [ __ ] violence i'm not a
domestic violence type of [ __ ]
i'll choke you you know
no
no i'm not a domestic violence type of
guy bro that's never been my mo
i had domestic violence that turned into
three different [ __ ] things man
that's not never been my [ __ ] emma at
all
so
it's like a place that you know it was a
dark place for me how did you get a
stolen car
you don't i i
it was like good and bad like i really
got
i really found myself as a comic there
in a way right from there i moved to l.a
it went over that hump i couldn't do it
in denver
so seattle served me his purpose but
it's one of those places that you've
been there
you did it and you move on to middle
school yeah take middle school once
you've gone through it you don't want to
[ __ ] go back and that's how i feel
guys i feel like that about a lot of
places i've been to that said i'm 52.
how much longer do i have on this planet
i want to go to places i'm really not
crazy about
or the places that i feel comfortable in
you know that i have a good time at
i don't care how much you pay me doing
this [ __ ] if i don't have a good time
time in your [ __ ] town i don't want
to [ __ ] be there you know
i like seattle i had a great time there
nothing like that it was just a bad luck
[ __ ] city for me you know
it'd be nice if you could have the
opportunity
like even even if you don't do it no no
not to seattle but to other places like
what
like you just had canada england
anywhere listen let me ask you something
guys
you know me a long time i'm going to do
something might do it
when i had the opportunities to fly
those places
i had zero interest in doing it
you're following me i've always been one
of those people listen
four hours and i do it now because i
have to do it and i've learned how to
sit on a plane but do you think i'm one
of those [ __ ]
unless
i don't even know what what would it be
worth it for me to sit on a plane for 16
hours damn
16 hours joey d is on a plane
16 [ __ ] hours why is that so terrible
because it's you see for you you just
watch movies and you don't give a [ __ ]
you lay there like a bump on a log by
the time they come to wake you up you're
like can we do this back i didn't want
to get off the plane i want to do
another 16 hours i can't sit there for
16 hours i have a hard time on that
flight from atlanta that way that's like
six hours fort lauderdale tower those
are six hour [ __ ] flights dc to la it
was a six hour flight you know you could
you could mind [ __ ] yourself for two
even when i go super high with a star
super high i plan my highs and
everything i eat an edible when i'm on
the plane i eat two more
so you eat the first two you get the
your breakfast
and you watch a movie
right that's your first two then your
next two maybe you take out a pad you
get the ipod out the ipad you list the
music you're [ __ ] high as [ __ ]
those last two hours are brutal you
check facebook you check twitter
you write a little bit but you're still
sitting the [ __ ] down bro you're hungry
you don't want no [ __ ] peanuts you
don't want nothing that they got after
that those sandwiches are horrific
all you want to do is [ __ ] land bro
and now after those six hours guess what
i got another 10 to come to your [ __ ]
country to do what
another hour to immigration i gotta walk
then i gotta find food i like
people listen just forget it it's not
gonna work out i went to jamaica the
next dig and do the same thing when
you're leaving yeah when i went to
jamaica that time and i saw those
chickens
how skinny they weren't how they were
walking around dog i didn't even eat at
the hotel
then i went to mcdonald's i didn't trust
the burgers once i go international it's
not good for uncle joey people
i don't trust [ __ ] i really don't i've
never liked it even hawaii as a kid
i went to hawaii with a bag of coke dog
it wasn't for me
it was a different time i'm gonna have
to go now with the baby and the wife
but at that time i was like a baby
reporter
at that time when i was 21 22 i it's
after three days okay now we did it we
had some drinks we giggled i got eight
more days in this [ __ ] island walking
around rubbing coconut juice on me good
son get the [ __ ] out of here put me on a
plane back
i remember i took a gig to amsterdam man
to rotterdam
and man i was i don't know like 11 hour
flight
and man i fought with my girlfriend at
the time the whole time
so that kind of made the flag go faster
on the planet that's how we landed with
that crazy chick yeah by the time we
landed crazy crazy
the little one the fireball yeah
that chick was [ __ ] nice we broke up
we broke up when we landed bro
in amsterdam yeah and then you flew back
and you hooked back up with it no we
broke i missed my flight because i i um
uh right after i did my set i
disappeared bro i disappeared in
rotterdam
and i started bro i walked into a black
bar
and they were singing that they were
playing that i would say
i have to say black bar because there
was only black people in there
and i walked in there and they were
playing that song
if lovely knew it right i don't wanna be
wrong
and now i walked in a man
and i started like singing with them
and um
i went like i said man there was a guy
by the bar like joe diaz said
there was a guy by the bar there did you
get someone drugs yes
i just walked up to him how many drugs
did you get i [ __ ] my pants if i was
international helicopter
he gave me that i couldn't do why would
it be different because you ever see
locked up abroad yeah you can get locked
that's why it's [ __ ] different
[ __ ] because i don't know the
rules did you give him a piece of
brownie here i'm already i'm not having
any more edibles you got no choice i do
have a choice
you gotta call paula yeah no i'm sorry
what happened to what'd you cop i he
gave me um coke
but i want i don't knocked up already or
powder
powder no [ __ ] yeah man but i didn't
know and i went to the i went to the
other club to do it i don't want to do
it there
and then um i met this other guy there
and he took me to a house
and then and um we were just walking we
met these two [ __ ] bro like these two
crazy chicks
and you met two horses yeah
like they wanted a party and he goes hey
i want to have party we know i played we
do more blow
that's all right
we went to it was jamaican guy and these
two girls
and once we got there
man this dude got bought naked fast bro
i was like i was waiting for the drugs
man like april can we like you know get
hydrostatic can my nose get naked too
but but yeah and i stood there from
night from 11 10 o'clock at night
to like 7 11 in the morning i missed my
flight
and my group my my chill at the time
flew out without me
[ __ ] [ __ ] i know
well
we can't have two flights missed right
that's what she would end up flying
when i was in rotterdam man
and i stood at this house
and i knew like somehow when when you're
a drug addict
it's like
you you don't it doesn't take you
that
long to find drugs like when you want
them
you just know the right people it's like
your brain is programmed you know to
find the right people
like where the the guy at the bar or
some random guy
smoking a cigar with you you make a
connection with his eyeballs and you
know man like this guy could give me
what i want
so
i missed my flight
and we broke up
and i did i smoked heroin there at that
house for the first time
out of aluminum foil man
how was that [ __ ] that was good
i threw up right away i'm gonna lie
through up i threw up like five times at
the house but as long as you have money
man and you keep spending they don't
kick you out
do you throw up every time i threw up
every time i smoked crack for the first
time i don't know why because it feels
like i i went on top of a roller coaster
and did three phillips and came back
down
and you still want to do the drug yeah
i want to do more
i want to throw up again you have no
idea how
when you're on that drug journey and you
commit to that drug journey
what your life really becomes it becomes
a little horror you bump into other
people that like you that's the scary
thing when you bump into other people
that just like you
and they know where when i lived in
seattle towards the end
and i wouldn't be with carol when i
would stay with the cook from
the underground
it was like three days of being with
that dude what's that movie with johnny
depp and the [ __ ] guy benicio del
toro
fear and loathing yeah who's that about
um
it's like hanging out with him for three
days
you don't know what you're gonna do you
might snort ups you might do heroin
you might find blow i would wake up in
the middle of the night his window was
broken
he had uh he lived in a warehouse in one
of those redone warehouses where you to
pull the [ __ ] elevator down and
pull the string up to the fourth floor
loft and [ __ ]
and i remember waking up in the middle
of the night he's had two black guys
smoking crack
in the corner and just paying rent for a
couple hours
to smoke crack in the corner that's how
cool
this dude was but you never knew what
you were gonna he would charge them to
smoke crap or come down and wake you up
joey these guys got cracked let's smoke
with them oh you have to man
what
like like if there's a there's a guy
like if there's a guy
there's always a guy there
who's selling the drugs who doesn't live
there but if you're buying drugs in that
house you gotta share it with the people
who are there like the owner of the
house they're gonna give him a little
kibble you know [ __ ] a little corner
they'll just stare at you bro forever to
drug the [ __ ] world when you're in it
when you're in it
and you don't mind what you're gonna see
and what's cool
like i i remember going to studio 54
on a thursday night one time
and my friends going my friends going
they do blow
in the ladies bathroom
and going into the ladies bathroom the
place was huge
and they were every bad people were just
doing coke and women were coming in
going into a box sitting down peeing and
walking right out
but when i was looking at those people
in that back room
that basically they were just as [ __ ]
up as i was just doing coke
in somebody's bathroom but i remember
all those stories
all those dealers those bar people we
met maya
all those
all those [ __ ] dealers man
i never today i don't hate not one of
them remember the guy in houston
and the old last stop though
with a shaved head and his nephew was
david that's the boy that showed up to
hook me up at three in the afternoon
that was it like i'm bi blee wake up you
[ __ ] i'm up he was like a militant biker
mexican dog and he'd bring you coke on
thursday night and invite you to his
house
for cooking the next day
and one day i went over and they were
[ __ ] cooking mexicans cooking dog
meat [ __ ] beans rice making that
pulled pork fudge i don't eat that [ __ ]
i'm not going off and [ __ ]
yeah man i've had some great dealers you
know and i wish them all the love in the
world and
that's what they did when you talk to
them and get to know them it's really
interesting why they sell drugs how
often did they get arrested
you know i didn't i didn't really ask
them about their resume lee i didn't
really think it was well like
when you were wait
all right no no would you ever
just be around and then your director
will get arrested and you have to find a
new drug dealer like you have to well
these guys were drug dealers when i went
into different cities yeah but like kids
i grew up with
yeah you take a pinch you take a scare
you you know something happens listen
most people don't make it in it for 30
or 40 years
most people don't do it they're smart
enough to get the [ __ ] out
there's people that have figured out a
way to do it and stay under that line
just to make a little extra money maybe
it's but to them it's a lot of [ __ ]
money
to them it's a lot of [ __ ] money i
went to school with a kid
that when i was getting into that whole
drug thing the guy was talking about
patty d that's where this kid was
getting this coke from
that kid today still forgets [ __ ] up
i don't think he deals anymore but i
know that he could hook people up and i
know that he owns like a couple plumbing
companies and he's got a girlfriend out
here a russian chick he's my age like a
20 year old girlfriend out here so he
made a ton of [ __ ] money selling
drugs there's a ton i mean i don't
advocate
but again
who buys
how the reason why escobar was making 66
million dollars a day
was because guys like us were [ __ ]
doing the drug
that's the bottom [ __ ] line
that's the bottom [ __ ] line
to that amount every day that's crazy
the [ __ ] like to get high though
people like to get out bro when that
when cocaine came on the scene those
style of drugs
it was a huge impact
how much how much how much would you
spend a week
when my mother first died
and i was a sophomore in high school in
the very beginning i was probably
spending 100 a week
400 a month now you think of 400
today is a lot of money a month i was in
high school
because i was buying 250s i would buy
like a 50 on a tuesday and split it with
two of us and then another 50 on
thursday and split it
and then as you got older
as i got older i i spent money but i
also find ways to do the drug on other
people's money oh yeah yeah someone said
that before
you know so
i'm just trying to think all right so i
get an eight ball i get three and a half
grams but
150 dollars right
all right let's pretend i get three and
a half grams for two hundred dollars
okay but you get a gram for a hundred
okay you come to me you want a gram i
charge you a hundred
he comes to me he wants a gram i get him
a hundred
i go buy the eight ball give it to you
as is and i still got a gram and a half
just for taking the ride
i make more than you
for taking the [ __ ] ride then when
you paid the hundred dollars for
that's how i dealt
i dealt the two friends that i knew just
to help me deal
so i would sit at home and also not like
if i knew
that somebody was getting good coke i'd
bait you
that was my job i was a junkie i'd have
to bet you leave what are you doing
today
i'm staying home with paul listen
fuckball listen what's going on the
armenians just call me he's got a
[ __ ] batch of coke that'll knock you
for a loop so i would try to bait your
scent your addictive sense of you know
really really what what you want to
charge for a gram 100
okay what time are you gonna meet me
i'll meet you in 10 minutes i got your
hundred
i got your hundred now i need another
hundred to get an eight ball
you're following me so you're not really
a drug dealer i'm not gonna go to jail
to get a gram for felipe that's my
brother
well you don't know it he don't give a
[ __ ] he's good he wants a hundred
dollars he don't give a [ __ ] how we get
it
that's what i talk about dealing
that's a different type of deal i was
just trying to like imagine how many
people had to be buying how much coke
to
buy to need 65 million dollars tonight
when you go home
get the [ __ ] calculator you're a
computer you're a college graduate
figure out 52 states
and figure out what how much a key was
in 1985.
in 1985 and just in the corner like you
said in the corner where i was hanging
out at they did a little raid
luckily i had a bad ankle when i was in
there
they they estimated these kids where i
was hanging out at
just on that little half a block they
were estimated they were making 65 000
a month
the mafia
lost control
when they got away from the street trade
they lost the control gangs nobody was
taxing nobody nobody was taxing nobody
no more and that's where your money is
if you told me today listen this is an
interesting book
how about the guy who came out 94 the
last don what was his name joey messina
jordan messina came out of prison the
first thing he did was closed all the
social clubs
he did like three things that were just
unheard of done
no more for us to survive
this is what we have to do
but one of the things he didn't do was
control the streets
you have to control those [ __ ]
streets because if not the latin kings
you know have 66 all you know again
that's what they do they make money all
street sales when you go down here at
night
instead of making a [ __ ] left out
here right make a right and go up there
and go on that street and go [ __ ] up
a few miles see what happens see what it
turns into
give it four or five miles and see if
there's a kid on the street
and he's walking real slow like making
believe he's looking for a dime
go ahead pull over and ask him that
you're lost
i dare you pull over and go i'm lost is
that all you'd ask you should look for
somebody walking that's it how you doing
i'm lost i'm looking for north hollywood
oh
make it right hey bro you need anything
what are you talking about
i could go for a soda no no
you want some grass or some coke or
something
there you go
and while you sell it to him he'll tell
you i'm here every night
and then you go away and you come back a
weekly and then he is doing the same
[ __ ] looking for a nickel
it's [ __ ] amazing
i wonder how you learn and the guy
that's watching him is the guy at the
bodega
his stash isn't at the bodega his stash
is upstairs
but the bodega guy is watching that
block so he's watching this block that
guy
so right now you got three guys on four
different corners it's 11 o'clock at
night
if the cops pull up them we're sitting
outside talking [ __ ] about comedy what
are you guys doing out here you guys
drinking no no
we're just saying we don't want to go
home we just we work days
and after a while the cops will leave
you alone
it's not till they get a complaint
and there's three guys out there at two
in the morning chasing cars
one of the last guys i was buying coke
from was a guy that sold coke on sunset
and western
[ __ ] crazy mexican
i met him at el compadre one night in
the back he was sweating profusiously
and [ __ ] because he would run
and he told me because i don't hang here
i hang behind
western and sunset just go there and
drive around a few times i'll see your
car there's a mcdonald's on the corner
he would be living in those bushes bro
that's not a [ __ ] fake story i tell
on stage that the guy would run up to me
and [ __ ] he pulled me over
and then without me saying a word you
know how white dealers go to you are you
a police officer you have to tell me by
law
this guy would push it to the next level
he would just take a coke rock out of
the satchel and put it in your [ __ ]
nose before you said anything
there was no chance you telling them
whether you were a cop or not you were a
little taste a little taste and he put
it up in your [ __ ] nose you'd be
[ __ ] gagging to that and then he'd go
get get his way
fifty dollars with you the cheap [ __ ]
and he'd go in his bag and he put it
right in your hand it was a nice rock no
wrapper no [ __ ] aluminum foil no
nothing
and then you got back in your car and
you just drove back to my [ __ ] house
how do you like them there [ __ ] oh i
remember one time it was hot with that
dude around and you said i went to your
house looking for stuff you said felipe
the car fell around three times and look
it was three cops
waiting for somebody to come out of your
apartment
yeah there was something there was like
four cops and you were never then the
little mexican dude had just shown up
you gotta have those type of eyes i know
when [ __ ] cops are cause carlito's
way said the streets are always watching
always watching oh yeah let me give a
shout out to these sponsors get the [ __ ]
out of here number one my main people
over at on it always supporting you with
nutritious
[ __ ] unbelievable
what am i talking about nutritious
i'm talking about honor baby number one
and complete earth grown nootropics you
got beautiful alpha brain they've got my
favorite of all time what's the [ __ ] you
drink what's the cocoa you drink
cacao cacao that's what they put in
there forced chocolate that's why the
chocolate shakes are so great
over it on it on it's got some
supplements that'll knock your dick in
the [ __ ] dirt you understand me from
the hemp force
protein powder at 16 grams of protein
per scoop to the honored alpha brain
this [ __ ] will [ __ ] [ __ ] your world
that shroom tech sport that is the [ __ ]
jack shrew spec shroom tech immune
they've got a great selection of stuff
from the testosterone they've got stuff
that'll rock your [ __ ] world don't
bump into that please go away take
pictures after the show uh
so go to shroom go to alpha brain right
now
and press and what lee
personally go to
church church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off your first
order but look thoroughly at this stuff
and read what's in everything you'll be
pretty much uh satisfied alpha brain has
a 30
a 30-day money-back guarantee wouldn't
even want the [ __ ] product back
if it doesn't do what we say it does for
you send it back we don't want the
product just tell us it don't work
we'll send you a gita's back all right
it's that [ __ ] simple number two
i got four pam me undies
right my house i worked when i go to jiu
jitsu or the gym why because it takes
the moisture away from my nut sack my
[ __ ] it keeps everything nice and
[ __ ]
i'm sorry i don't know what the material
is
and the [ __ ] me undies
what is it
mortal i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
but i will tell you one thing about me
on these they're comfortable as well
sorry about that people i was joking on
something there's [ __ ] dust the
allergens in the room
like i said on it but number two
for comfortable
tremendous underwear
go to me undies i got woman and men's
underwears t-shirts
shorts hooded sweatshirts if they
[ __ ] don't have the comfortable stuff
i got these pair of red warm-up pants
that they sent me that are as
comfortable as all hell
do you understand me the the [ __ ]
the uh the boxer shorts they have the
women on these comfortable as well the
thing i like about me on these the most
is the way they fit they're comfortable
i don't have them on right now like a
lot of they have my beyond these on
right now no i don't i have mom when i
work out because they make
you ever go to the [ __ ] jiu jitsu to
the gym
when your shorts fall and your
your pants aren't comfortable any other
underwear i take to a gym feel [ __ ]
uncomfortable when i wear my undies they
feel [ __ ] great and when i leave
there it's not like they're all damp my
nuts are sweaty nothing like that i mean
it is nice and dry everything is nice
and dry nice and moist so do me a favor
go to me on these right now go look at
the fine selection of men and women
underwears they have they're going to
give you 20 off your first order
and free shipping in canada and the
united states go to me on these right
now and press on what my brother joey
joey j-o-e-y and get 20 off your first
dollar all right and free [ __ ]
shipping nobody else does that in the
business to your door underwear
comfortable great colors they fit great
detriment what happened shipping's
expensive yeah shipping is real [ __ ]
they even went up again yeah you ship a
lot of stuff right yeah [ __ ] prices
went up again the ship a mug to england
is like 22 [ __ ] dollars you might as
well drink it out of your hand
the [ __ ] you walk around with a [ __ ]
bug
and [ __ ] listen
every week marketing changes on me all i
know is one thing
nature box has great goddamn snacks
those jalapeno cashews
those chocolate yum yums the
vanilla almond granola i mean these
things are world class nutritious
delicious snacks okay the thing about
nature boxes it gets delivered to your
door right to your home you don't have
to go to a grocery and get through bat
you walk through a girl you want
everything you want to just go home and
be there this happens with naturebox
naturebox.com delivers fresh nutritious
boxes straight to your house i mean like
i said the vanilla almond granola
the the plant the south pacific plantain
chips i mean they got stuff that'll blow
your mind the great thing about nature
box is that they cut keep adding stuff
every week every time you go you can
switch up the order but listen do me a
favor
my personal favorites so far
have to be the jalapeno cashews that
they [ __ ] blew my mind what do they
taste like like jalapeno cashews that's
what they tell you that tastes like
filet mignon
and i like the sesame sticks they're
always gonna be my favorite but do me a
big favor right
they also have the smart snack guarantee
if there's anything you don't like
let the helpful folks at naturebox.com
know and they replace the box they'll
replace it in there in your next box so
do me a do me a favor right now i can't
read without my glasses i'm terrible at
it but just work on me
so go online get your first box at
naturebox.com
joey okay that's naturebox.com joey head
to naturebox.com.com
joey right now
to unbox a world of taste and
possibility that comes delivered to your
door one last time that's naturebox.com
joey and get your first block first box
of beyond tasty hand-picked snacks
direct to your doorstep all right and
remember the smart snack guaranteed
that's all i need to tell you guys today
so with the undies
on it
and uh naturebox.com i love you guys i
thank felipe for coming on the show
what's up don't forget this weekend i'm
in vegas
uh friday saturday sunday saturday
nights when i'm taping the special new
york city is sold out next week the two
shows that got them
toledo funny bone all right stay black i
want to thank rodrigo my main man torrez
yeah man i'm good hell yeah thank you
for coming up tonight and giggling
[ __ ] always a pleasure to have you
here we gotta be some pissing
[ __ ] we drank a lot of guys
oh yeah that's those edibles they
dehydrate they really could uh plug the
shows in west nyack yeah levity live
what are they
we're going to be at levity live in west
niagara october 22-25 that's me and
rodrigo
and um parlor bar in seattle in
washington october the 10th
river center comedy club san antonio
texas november 4th
remember november 5th to the 8th you can
see our shows at philippersworld.com
rodrigo and i we have a podcast it's
called what's up full podcast
this week we have um john sally oh yeah
from sportscenter and [ __ ]
and all that [ __ ] beautiful i'm excited
food share and then i i just put up a
new flying g-radio with joe perez that's
great i'm real [ __ ] excited george
perez
what are you going to close with
you you said um
seriously
i had brothers i love you guys stay
black
thank you very much for listening to the
church see you in the lobby we're so
full i'll see you next week
yeah man
don't forget about us